The Joe Rogan experience.
I have avoided games on my phone for a
very specific reason why I have a problem
with games. Like you said,
you got hooked on it. Yeah.
You have a bad ass gaming rig over
there. I saw that gaming rig, game room,
the land. But that's all for first
person shooters while we're here. Okay.
CanNot have a game that I love on
my phone. Why not have that? Why?
Because I'm a child. Yeah, you
get obsessed with it. Yeah.
I don't have that kind of control.
If I have a fucking awesome game that's
on my phone. Yeah, that's my life.
My life's gone now. You go get
the game on me. Everywhere I go.
What apps you have on your phone?
What apps, what else keeps you going?
I have a bunch of, um, normal
apps like Instagram and Twitter,
but I have a bunch of cool ones.
Like some star map shit.
What do you have never looked for this,
but I just found some playing
quake on their phone. Oh, ah, yeah.
That Xbox controller.
It's sorta like that as a controller you
can excrete dope shit, but they play,
they have quake three port it on there.
God Damn it.
See why the fuck would you telling me
that whenever I looked before it son of a
bitch. It looks like it
was two dimensional though.
Or not two d but it didn't have an
up and and down. Yeah. Addiction.
Now congratulations on your new
addiction. No, I'm not going to do it.
I don't have anything on my phone.
I don't even have chat.
I played chess on my phone for a little
while and I didn't even like that. Yeah,
cause I was started going, hmm, how do
I get better at this? I'm like shut up.
I'm try saying that I had to just shut it
off and we put that goddamn thing down.
Do you have to pick and choose what you
want to devote your time and energy? So,
so what are your,
what are your top three things that you
put time and interest to that aren't
your family right now? Well, work stuff.
It's mostly work stuff or martial arts,
right?
So it's like work stuff is a stand up,
which is the most time consuming because
I have multiple sets tonight and I'm
always writing, always tweaking and
listening to the pouring. So how do you,
how do you do at your standup stuff?
So I want to get this shit.
You want to get into stand up?
Not really.
Well that was kind of thinking about
how do I get into stand up comedy?
People watch my videos. Like while
you're kind of funny, you're funny.
You should do stand up. I was like,
Shit, I'll trust me. I'm a professional.
You're funny guy. You can
totally do it. Thank you.
All you have to do is go to an open
mic night. So yeah. What I suggest,
go to an open mic night and see
how terrible everybody is. Right.
And then you'll be inspired to try to say,
you're going to be terrible too.
Don't get me wrong.
I was terrible when I first started,
but you'll probably be better than most.
Really? Yeah. And that's all you need.
All you need is people.
If you say something people ha ha ah,
just that's all you need.
Just a little chunk. One guy
in the front row. Yes. Okay.
I gotta remember I got an ember.
Yeah.
Like I can do this and you'll figure
it out and you'll get better at it and
you'll work at it and you'll tweak it.
And how old are you? 36. You can do it.
You still have time still alive when once
a cutoff date. 40 Shit. Kill yourself.
I don't mean that. Don't
listen to me. You'll never
just jokes folks. Just joking.
Kidding Jay k. But if you, if you're
a person who can make people, uh,
and you are willing to
dedicate yourself to it,
it's not like you have to have certain
amount of flexibility or you know,
a certain amount of physical
strength, right? No,
it's just can you make people
laugh? Okay. Then you can do it.
Are you going to pull it off?
Right? That's another question.
So how do you get inspiration? How do you
see you sit down? Yeah. This is funny.
Now write this down. How do you get
inspiration for that? I think it's,
you have to be what I would call
a professional, and this is a,
I've gotten this from Steven
Pressfield who wrote the war of art,
which is a great book.
And I'm also got it from reading Stephen
King on writing and talking to a lot of
different writers about how
they handle things, right?
If you just waited to be inspired,
and that's the only time you wrote,
you wouldn't have half as much
shit. Right? Not even close Britain,
not even close.
Half as much good material as you
do if you decide I'm going to write.
So I sit down and I write and sometimes
I don't know what the fuck to write
about. And I just started writing. I just
started rambling. Right? And a lot of the,
like the first 20 minutes might be total
horse shit that doesn't get me anywhere.
But then I got an idea. What about
that? Well, why the fuck do we do that?
And then I'll start writing about that.
Well, this and that will make things up.
I'll make up a fact and then I'll
argue against that fact. Right?
And then maybe I'll find out what the
real fact is and see if I can argue that
way. And then I'll, I'll, I'll,
and then I'll, and I'll give up.
I'll get to like 1700 words, something
like that. I'll shut the laptop.